Speaker 1: There are growing questions, and we
still don't know the full scope of this about what
the hell were police doing during the 40 to 60
minute period that the 18 year old Duval de Texas
shooter was in the school? Now, this is not about
criticizing police. It's about thinking critically
about the supposed solutions that Republicans
say would be solutions. We need to think about
whether that makes any sense given what we are
now learning took place in Uvalde, Texas. We are
now learning that while the gunman was inside the
school for 40 to 60 minutes after being confronted
by an armed officer, police were just outside
stopping parents desperate from going in to try
to stop the shooter. Now you can say, well, those
parents could have gotten themselves help skilled.
True. But what why were why weren't the police
in the school? Why weren't the police actually
doing something during those 40 to 60
minutes that would have had an impact?
We now have footage. Okay. There is now
footage of armed police outside the school
during the shooting, pinning a man believed to be
a parent to the ground. Okay. Take a look at this.
And you might. So you see here police
have a guy pinned to the ground.
That's not the shooter. That's believed to
be a parent or some kind of school employee
desperate to go in and do something
because the police weren't.
Speaker 2: Sure got here.
Speaker 1:
Okay. I think you get the idea. Department of
Public Safety director Steve McCraw told reporters
that 40 to 60 Minutes elapsed from when the gunman
opened, fired until when the tactical team got in
and shot the gunman. According to officials,
the shooter went into a classroom and locked
the door. Police on scene left him in there when
Border Patrol showed up. They couldn't break down
the door. And after 40 to 60 Minutes, a member of
the school staff unlocked the classroom door with
a key. So we're still getting the details here.
This is increasingly being looked at. What on
earth happened? But my point is less about I mean,
listen, we need to investigate why police did what
they did. There are anecdotal reports and it's
still early, but there are anecdotal reports that
the reason it was Border Patrol ultimately was
that the police on scene were were refusing to
go in. Now, that's just it's an assertion that's
been made. And we want to be really careful and
make sure we know what actually happened. But
the question we need to grapple with here is
if this is what trained police did, how on earth
do we think that armed civilians in the schools
are the solution armed teachers or armed janitors
or armed lunch ladies? It doesn't make any sense.
And so we need to figure out the specifics of
what happened here for sure. But there are a lot
of other questions that remain unanswered.
Bigger picture about what should be done